these children were killed
in various ways unfortunately some of
them died from diseases like
tuberculosis and pneumonia but other
kids were drowned some were shot
and some were disposed of in other ways
which they've yet to determine because
in a lot of these cases like this u.s
indian school they actually were never
able to find the remains of the body
although the the bodies of these
children are actually said to be buried
nearby now the school in and of itself
is extremely problematic kids were
pulled at least from this particular
school
40 tribes at least were represented
in this u.s indian school where kids
were taken from their homes their
parents uh forced to cut their brains
never allowed to speak the language that
they had grown up speaking we all have
to keep in mind that this is a federally
ran program now the reason things took a
dark turn is because mr william pratt
actually lived by one motto you kill
the indian and you save the man
so hearing that a general started a
school like this with that particular
motto it's no wonder that thousands of
kids ended up dead in my opinion i think
it's safe to say that the federal
government much like in the situation
with the tuskegee project doesn't really
want it well known or well documented
that they were indeed responsible not
just for the death of indigenous chil
kids and people
hundreds of years ago but this was 1934.
these kids were literally being killed
in the 20th century
you